so welcome everyone um to the
fall 2021 refugee seminar series today
we have the pleasure of having professor
logan talking about activism from exile
and how active activists abroad
influence politics back home
professor nogen is an assistant
professor of political science at yale
university she is the author of after
repression how polarization develops
demographic democratic transition
published by princeton university press
in 2020. her research explored the
political psychology of religion and
repression in the middle east and has
been published or is for coming in the
american journal of political science
comparative political studies journal of
conflict resolution proceeding of the
national academy of science
and war politics
professor nogen holds a doctorate in
politics from princeton university as
well as a bachelor in arts in arabic and
mastering arts in arabic studies both
from georgetown university she
previously was a postdoctoral research
fellow in the middle east initiating
at harvard kennedy school of government
welfare center for science and
international affairs
um so this is a hybrid uh
seminar we have uh attendees both in the
luz center and in so so professor nougat
the floor is yours thanks
great well thank you so much for joining
me and liz and um to everyone else who's
joining online i really appreciate the
program uh over the last two years that
i've been working on this project it's
obviously been quite interrupted by
um the pandemic and
the small grant that i had from the
program allowed me to basically shift a
lot of what i was doing uh to online
research and online interviews which
i'll talk a little bit about during the
presentation
so
the broader project that i'm going to
talk about today
takes us and start the arab spring
uprisings from 2011. uh to 2012.
um this is a picture from uh talker
square which was the epicenter of the
revolution in egypt
um in my first book i talked a lot about
how essentially the revolution um went
wrong right so how it um resulted in uh
authoritarian retrenchment within two
years
but uh one of the first quotes that i
cite in the book is from somebody who
was antagonia for those 18 days of
protest he describes it as being like a
dream so it felt like everything was
possible there was a sense of
camaraderie with strangers and
countrymen
um one author describes it as liminality
right that everything that felt like it
had been established was now up for
question in really positive and
interesting ways
um and for a brief moment um in the
egyptian case there was actually
civilian government so from 2012 to 2013
of course was a muslim brotherhood
affiliate but there was um someone who
was not a military figure in church
the damage within two years the
revolution is essentially over um what
i'm going to call it and i'll define
this in a couple of slides is a defeated
revolution
this gentleman here is obviously
the current president of egypt um in
july 2013 he announced on national
television that the military would be
performing a coup removing the
democratically elected president uh from
office
um he then won re-election uh twice with
kind of the standard 94 97 of the vote
in
um a pretty you know regular
authoritarian election
since then he's overseen
of authoritarianism that's much worse
than what his um predecessors oversaw so
in the first year after the coup there
were 40 000 people that were arrested
most affiliated with the muslim
brotherhood
since then that number has grown to a
hundred thousand probably sixty thousand
of those are political prisoners
um
and beyond that um cece has recently
reached his constitutional term limit
and so he pushed for new amendments to
not only allow him to stay in power
through 2030 but also institutionalizing
military rule in the country
so egypt um even though this is
obviously a very heartbreaking and sad
story it's also not an anomalous story
so most revolutions fail right two out
of three since 1900 to 2014 there have
been 345
revolutionary episodes
two thirds of those have failed right
only 123 have actually resulted in
meaningful political economic or social
change
um
and what's interesting is that despite
its prevalence right this is the modal
outcome we know very little about what
happens
afterwards um we know a lot about
successful revolutions uh the literature
tends to focus on these
are interesting and uh they're
particularly
unique in certain ways
so what i'm going to talk about today
is
a new book project and a related paper
on
about taking as its inspiration what has
happened in egypt over the last 10 years
so i am particularly interested in how
activists experience defeated revolution
and then how it affects their subsequent
political behavior
i'm going to start by giving you an
overview of my book tentatively titled
exiles how activists abroad influence
politics back home
um what i'm gonna do in this is kind of
conceptualize what defeated revolution
is for activists these are people who
are
um acutely aware of what's going on
they're also involved with both both
planning and executing revolutions
what i'm going to argue is that a
combination of experiences
and the context that they end up in
as you'll see in the case of egypt most
activists who are not in jail are now in
exile um this has quite a profound
impact on whether they continue to be
active as activists and the nature of
that activism
and as i mentioned you know i'm going to
focus mostly on egyptian exiles though
syrian iraqi and libyan exiles come up
as an interesting comparison yes
then i'm going to talk about um a
related but standalone co-author paper
with alex siegel at the university of
colorado boulder she really is the
expert for dealing with arabic language
digital data
what we do here is look at a specific
case of protests in egypt in september
2019 where exiles were extremely
influential in introducing and then
amplifying information that then
resulted in pretty significant protests
okay
so what comes after defeated revolution
this is kind of a big question that i'm
interested in in this book
um i have a quote up here that hopefully
you can see online as well just read it
this is from sarah high the late
egyptian activist
she said as saint just said those who
make half a revolution dig their own
graves this is literally not just
figuratively true most of us are now in
the grave in prison or in exile
uh sarah was a communist
activist who died
by suicide following a pretty terrible
ordeal um she waved um an lgbtq pride
flag at a missionary on a concert in
cairo resulted in her being arrested
tortured um the ptsd that she suffered
from was pretty cute um she ended up in
exile in osho toronto uh osho canada
so what
is the experience like for activists
um there are some obvious you know ways
that we can think about this first
there's a decrease in the quality of
democracy in egypt right there was this
one-year civilian rule there were two
years of elections there were two years
of liberalization so activists will
experience this rate as a decrease in
that quality
there's this appointment about politics
right if you remember that first quote i
just showed you um at the beginning it
felt like a dream it felt like
everything was possible life was going
to change significantly both politically
socially economically
personally a number of people that i
talked to for this project have had
major falling outs with family and
friends um
in ways that also uh you know speak to
the personal aspects of defeated
revolution
in addition especially in the case of
egypt the instability that the
revolution introduced and then it's
defeat um exacerbated
uh these folks are going to be exposed
to economic decline
but most importantly and this is why i
told you sarah's backstory um
at a moment of defeat of revolution the
state is going to be quite defensive
right they're re-establishing themselves
what's happened is that activists or
those that are targeted most acutely by
state repression as i mentioned 100 000
have been arrested 60 000 of those are
political prisoners
countless have been disappeared into the
system
their lawyers and their families can't
find them
what i'm going to focus on here is this
group of individuals who have been
exiled so there's potentially tens of
thousands who have been exiled
um
this is you know a form of course
migration that functions in a way that's
very similar to regression
so before i get too much further let me
define a couple of terms just so we're
all on the same page here
so first the way that i think of
revolution
is a mass siege of established
government involving completing
competing claims of sovereignty which
aims to displace the
incumbent regime and substantially alter
the established order now uh scholars
will often differentiate between
political revolutions right where the
established order is that's being
changed is political um my interlocutors
really think of political social and
economic changes going together so the
established order here is kind of
society but large
what i mean by defeated revolution is
when this process doesn't happen right
so the competing centers of sovereignty
emerge the way tilly talks about this um
there's a revolutionary situation
there's a potential for change and it
doesn't result in the final instance
in meaningful um change to the
established order
i think of this a bit differently than
other scholars of political science do
um often there's a focus on
kind of the the
sequence or process through which
revolutions emerge or the structural
predecessors that determine whether or
not a revolution
is successful eventually what i'm
thinking about this as is a
participatory experience so something
that happens to
activists not necessarily something that
they do or particip
something that they do um
second activists um this is a definition
i take from you yusuf bill sheffley an
individual with long-term involvement in
the form of collective protest action in
the context of movements groups or
campaigns that were structured to at
least some extent there's two uh two
parts that i want to highlight here so
first long-term involvements is an
important thing activists are people who
think of
activism as a political behavior that
they use you know not just in the
revolutionary situation that i just
referred to but as a way of contesting
politics more broadly um in the case of
egypt this means that they're not just
active in 2011. they're active before
2011 and they're active since
second um this definition speaks to the
collective
right so individual protest is very
interesting but it's hard to generalize
it's hard to observe
we are being involved in movements
groups unions organizations
things that are you know collective
entities is really important for
thinking about somebody as being an
activist
and then finally exile this is one of
the key terms in
um the book project so as i mentioned it
results from course migration regimes
use this as a political
uh punishment right for political
behavior
it's very similar to other logics in
terms of why regimes use it right so the
idea here is to demobilize individuals
fractured the opposition
make anti-regime um mobilization
unsuccessful and ineffective
one thing that's become very obvious in
my research is that this is a difficult
thing to sometimes pin down
one thing that happens to people or one
kind of migration status that exiles
hold
so the way i talk about this in the book
is that there are both explicit and
formal forms of exile and then implicit
and informal forms of exile so with
explicit informal here the focus is
going to be on revocation of citizenship
a travel ban
with informal it's much more
you know the regime shows up at your
house in the form of the police
makes it very evident that you're no
longer a protected citizen less formal
but still you know just as as
potentially scary
um an additional thing that i've found
in some of my research uh
so often
um exiles will also talk about the
decline in the quality of politics and
economics in egypt as a reason for why
they've left so i'm trying to think
about how that might also be a regime's
strategy
or
a yeah a tactic of kind of wanting
people to leave
so where have egypt's activists gone
since 2011. um both of these graphs this
and the next one are
inflows and then activist claims excuse
me asylum claims to oecd countries
um as you can see 2011 is going to be
this dotted line this is the year of the
revolution 2013 is about here so these
are major events first the revolution
and the coup
um
prior in the decade prior to the
revolution there were about 239 000
egyptian migrants two oecd countries
that number grows to uh 339
000
after
and we can see an even bigger spike here
right so before the revolution
about 13 000 egyptians had applied for
asylum in oecd countries
the 10 years after the revolution 116
000 had applied for asylum um so
significant numbers um particularly
after 2011. that's kind of interesting
right i mean in a case like syria the
revolution has led to
a civil war the security context has
declined
we might expect a graph like this and in
fact you know the numbers are quite
large but egypt hasn't become any safe
any less safe
in terms of national security in the
last 10 years so there's clearly
something politically motivated going on
here
from my qualitative evidence and my
interviews with activists um
you know the one thing that i've
uncovered is that the
demographics of migrants have changed
over the last 10 years
so the brotherhood
its activists its supporters its leaders
those who weren't arrested
left 2013 essentially as the coup is
happening and on
in 2014 the uh cc regime having
more or less dealt with the brotherhood
um in both legal and repressive ways
starts to look at the rest of the
act of opposition and starts to target
non-sms activists and they start to
leave in larger numbers starting in 2014
and then again in 2018 right around the
elections
what's been interesting is watching
these cells of activists popping up in
different locations over the last 10
years
um so you know there are certain western
destinations in germany we have berlin
in the us there's new york city and
washington dc
um there's also places you know closer
to the region including doha and
istanbul
um interestingly
there are
um three interesting um cells of exiles
in italy milan
uh korea and seoul and lebanon beirut um
this has to do with the ease with which
egyptians can travel to these places
they don't need visas to go into these
countries um and particularly in seoul
this was an early uh
hub and since the migration restrictions
have actually been you know put down so
there's not as many people migrating
there
so the broader question i'm asking
in this project is you know
what's been interesting is is watching
how activism does or does achieve once
people
left the country right so first what
influences whether activists continue to
be activists in exile
and second one influences that form
right what they're doing as activism
as a first uh choice right so here we
have activism we have our activists who
are then being exiled um in the first
order they have kind of three main
choices right do they cease to be
activists that's individual
demobilization they leave the movement
they leave activism
do they convert
uh this is the term that i use here
right do they start to mobilize on other
issues concrete example of this might be
egyptian activists in
exiled in berlin who start to work on
migration issues in germany or the green
movement right so no longer focus on
domestic issues in egypt
if they continue
right to mobilize on egyptian-based uh
domestic issues they have them three
main behavioral choices
do they work as an activist to prepare
the movement for regime change down the
road or do they take a more combative
approach right
either promoting bottom-up regime change
through supporting networks back home on
the ground
or promoting top-down regime change by
lobbying the their new host governments
in their new countries
theorizing how they make these decisions
um i think both combination individual
and contextual factors come into play
but at different times during the
decision process
so in terms of individual factors i
think this is really important for that
first decision right whether or not you
continue an activism um convert that
activism or uh cease to be an activist
um here looking at some of the
literature and the bio uh biographical
effects of activism we see that the
length of activism matters right so
people who joined activism before 2011
tend to be much more committed
in ways that suggest they're going to
continue even after they leave their
country
the existence of personal networks back
home right can the regime literally you
know repress your family even though
you're no longer part of uh kind of the
domestic sphere
experiences of repression can go one of
two ways so some people who experience
repression and torture as a result of
the defeat of the revolution
um
you know they're galvanized right
they're angry the parts of their
identity for which they were uh
repressed right are stronger and more
mobilizing
for other people they have real trauma
right real ptsd in ways that prevent
them from being an activist
and then finally i consider two
demographic uh conditions the first
class in education right so do you have
the literal resources that you need to
continue to be an activist particularly
when it's very difficult
and second are you in a phase of life
where you may be working on other things
right education or even having children
um this in the american literature is
particularly important for white people
individually demobilized from activism
in terms of the contextual factors i
look at three things the first regime
type right is this a democracy where
people have the ability to lobby their
representatives
have their
preferences accounted for in policies
what are the relationships like between
the new host country and the home
country
you'll see in
my cases right there's a very big
difference between the united states
germany and turkey in terms of their
relationship with egypt
and then finally thinking about
migration rate the extent to which
migrants um have essentially assimilated
right which has to do with the number of
migrants how they're treated
whether or not there are other similar
migrants who are treated similarly to
them in this case arab and muslim
migrants matters for whether or not
they're going to keep mobilizing on
domestic issues back home or
issues related to the new host country
so putting this all together this is the
the data that i've i'm working with it's
a mixed methods
project
much of this has been delayed by covet
but i'm hopeful that it's going to get
done in 2022.
as i mentioned the program's funding
allowed me to complete a data set of
egyptian migration
a data set of travel bans and arrests in
egypt under the cc regime and also to
keep translating and transcribing
my semi-structured interviews which i
was able to continue to do overseas for
the last 18 months
so just a couple of notes on some
preliminary findings these two gentlemen
were both um administrators of the we
are kind of tiny facebook page this was
an extremely important um facebook page
that organized the protests in 2011.
on the bottom we have
both of them have experienced coerced
migration they were both arrested
tortured
um both of them have experienced having
family members pressured by the regimes
they reacted in very different ways
so
on the top he now lives in san francisco
he's really no longer what we might call
an activist he does do some individual
mobilization but he's disconnected from
the networks of people that he worked
with before he said a couple of very
public um sad you know uh
meltdowns i guess he would call them
um and he now works in in the tech
industry
remains very
networked he's now living in new york
city
continues to very quietly mobilize among
both the german
and
the american
networks of exiles
then to speak a little bit about the
importance of context now in the united
states um there's been an interesting
development of the egypt human rights
caucus this is led by
um
in congress it's don baier and tom
malinowski i believe from virginia and
new jersey
here activists have been working on
forming this caucus uh to talk about
things like human rights
and
military aid to egypt so it's very
specific right we're not talking about
regime change here
and that has very much to do
with the nature of the relationship
between egypt and the united states
it's also shaped by the political
opportunity structure right so here they
form the caucus they're lobbying the
government because that's how politics
works in the united states
in the case of germany you see a much
more diffuse less organized less
hierarchical structure
there tends to be a lot of
cross-pollination berlin has a huge
syrian exile population
and so you see egyptians working on kind
of pan-arab issues this is a protest
that egyptians worked with palestinians
to mobilize these issues there's some
mobilization in terms of
lobbying the government or testifying in
front of the government on certain
issues but it tends to be much more
diffused much more focused on kind of
what we would
call traditional activism
so now i want to get into the
co-authored paper with alex siegel
in this case we're going to be looking
at specifically
protests in egypt in
2019 and how exiles participated in
introducing and mobilizing
these protests
the broader question we're asking is how
do exiles participate in contentious
politics back home in the digital age
and to theorize this we draw on three
sets of literature
um and some of their essential concepts
so first we think of the internet um as
extending the domestic sphere abroad
right so this is
a place in which you know there's a
transnational sense of political
identity um exiles who are no longer
physically located within the country
can continue to be in contact and even
deepen uh certain kinds of connections
with people back home
and it essentially allows uh political
excellence to have agency right to have
some kind of autonomy in influencing
domestic politics
second
kind of rely on the canonical um
models of how we think about people and
how they join rate of costly protest
mobilization to think about what the
internet might be doing similarly to
these classic models
so we know in the individual models of
protest mobilization that information
provision is extremely important right
so learning that lots of other people
support an oppositional position makes
it less costly for the individual
to join
um
what we're thinking about here is
digital information provision and here
you know this again you know speaks to
the the classic models but we're talking
about essentially when something goes
viral online right so when things are
posted by multiple people um in a way
that suggests that lots of people
support it
um
this is important for
authoritarian regimes in a way that it
may be less important for democratic
regimes right so online is slightly more
free at least in the context of egypt um
it may be the kind of place where
engaging with oppositional information
here meaning critical of the regime um
signal something right about how popular
an oppositional position is
and then finally we think that exiles
might actually have quite a unique role
to play um in digital information
cascade so as you saw
exiles obviously are all located outside
of the country some of them are located
in democratic context where they have
relatively more impunity right to be
posting oppositional information
um and doing so you know
over time and kind of inaccess in a way
that have they been in the country they
might have been repressed or censored in
some way
to think about how this whole process
works we draw the communications
literature to talk about three different
kinds of social media users so first
influencers these are
the users that see new content they make
memes they make hashtags
this case they also make videos
some of the literature refers to them as
idea starters
and there's amplifiers these are uh as
the literature calls them the fire hose
of knowledge they're doing all the uh
for lack of better word amplification
right of this information so taking the
content making it go viral
um
these are extremely important users
because they're often very active
they'll do things like
in in the case under consideration here
right they're going to retweet at a high
rate they're going to add people to
conversations and connect people
then finally we have consumers in our
theory these are also going to end up
being the protests uh
participants
um some of the literature calls these
people lurkers right they consume
content they look at content they might
be on the internet quite a bit
but they're not doing a lot of public
engagement right they might not be
retweeting or liking um
uh information in a way that we can
capture publicly
what we think
you know going into this and what we in
fact find is that exiles are
particularly influential when they are
influencers introducing that new
information
and when they're amplifying it as well
because of the relative impunity that
they can act with
but it's really important you know that
there is overlap in the amplifier and
consumer uh categories with domestic
users right otherwise it's just an
axillic
mobilization an exhilarat movement
so the case
that we're going to be talking about is
uh comes from september 2019 in egypt
this is muhammad ali he
in this video is located in spain
in south exile
prior to leaving egypt he had worked for
15 years as a contractor for the
egyptian military
in construction
he also worked as an actor which will
become important for thinking through
some of our general's generalizability
from this case
um in his videos which he starts posting
on september 2nd 2019 he calls out uh
the current regime for corruption he
called out two major generals by name
they've been in charge of the armed
forces engineering authority
um he claims that he's owed 220 million
egyptian pounds
um and he talks about all this
corruption that he experienced right the
cc regime has been spending quite a bit
of money constructing a new capital uh
constructing these villas for the
military um on the red sea and so he's
speaking to to this right uh he
witnessed firsthand quite a bit of
corruption
the president actually responds to him
after a whole week of videos
and in the hours after that response
happens muhammad ali
this gentleman right here
posts a number of videos and kind of
shifts from being
specifically focused on corruption to
calling for wider protests um broader
issues of corruption
um and repression
he posts videos from a number of
long-term activists so a sinai activist
and also
a former army officer and lawyer who now
works in human rights he's also
reposting a lot of videos that are
coming from both masked and unidentified
individuals claiming to be members of
the armed forces who support
the claims that he's getting
i should note they all get channeled
through ali's account in a way that
makes it really helpful for us to
basically track how this process um
unfolds over time
so the first protests happen on yeah
yeah just a quick question so does uh
muhammad ali have
uh
fossil family back in egypt that
presumably
by the regime
yeah
um
he has some i know
after all this kind of plays out he's
also
there's pressure that's put on him in
scenes as well
um
then i can talk a little bit more about
that in the queue
um
but i should just note um so he has both
a youtube account where he's posting
these videos he's a twitter account um
uh where he's retweeting this content
and then he also uh spreads most of
these things on facebook
um through different hashtags
so these are our
protests so the protests start on the
20th
uh the 21st and then the 27th the 27th
are going to be the largest ones the
regime responds in two ways so these uh
moments of mobilization so first they
flood the streets with police
um especially major squares where these
uh groups tend to congregate and start
protests
uh they arrest 4 321 individuals as a
result of participating
in these protests
they also use twitter's reporting
mechanism to shut down ali's account
i'll be able to show you that in a
couple of slides from now
and up to 150 accounts of related
activists who are highly engaged with
his contract
so to figure out
what's going on here right how exiles
this uh muhammad ali and those that
interact with him how do they you know
introduce information that then
mobilizes protests we use
a method called process tracing so this
is the analysis of diagnostic evidence
kind of a preponderance of evidence
from processes sequences and
conjunctures of events within a single
case
and process tracing is particularly good
for looking at the specific causes of
specific outcomes
um in this case what we do is
look at the introduction of information
the amplification of information the
consumption of information and our last
analysis is going to break that down at
a very fine grain some national level in
a way that suggests this information
consumption predicts um
protest mobilization at a very local
level
the digital data we have both captures
public and private engagement with this
content uh facebook we're going to have
um
data from public uh facebook pages
community pages
google trends is more of a private um
way to think about engagement with this
content
it's basically search trends that are
just aggregated by location
twitter allows us to again get that kind
of public engagement so are people
adding muhammad ali are they retweeting
are they liking
and finally youtube is again a bit more
private right so
when you think about likes and dislikes
that you can post on a youtube page
that's more public but there's also
information about just viewing a video
that we have
the non-digital data that we use here is
from daftar file it's a cairo based
organization that does real-time data
collection on contentious events
so first thinking about our influencer
as i mentioned um he starts on september
2nd and between september 2nd and
november 1st which is our period of
analysis he posts between one and seven
videos a day
um there's they're a bit front-ended um
but he's very active throughout this
period
he started a twitter account the same
day he posted his first video and so he
goes from having very i mean literally
zero followers to
excuse me this is uh
the number of tweets right so he he
starts from having very few tweets to
producing almost 6 000 by the time
um
this period is over
there are different moments when you can
figure out right that the regime is
starting to interfere
um some of these early ones
every time there's a vertical line right
a tweet has been deleted some of these
early ones are muhammad ali's censoring
himself
these
are much more likely based on secondary
information to be the regime shutting
down his account
here is his follower account so as i
mentioned you know he starts with very
few followers by the time of the first
protest he has 250 000 followers so he's
becoming central uh very influential
within certain uh networks of activists
in a way where he's the central node
and we can see this happening here
now to turn to the amplifiers um here we
have twitter data that we collected in
real time
and we're able to see
first of all that these these trends in
terms of engagement again either
retweeting or adding uh literally you
know replying or
tagging
him
it corresponds with the protests as
they're happening
we also disaggregate it by users who are
located inside of egypt and outside of
egypt
um what you can see here is that the
rates of engagement inside egypt at
least in this measurement rate are
higher overall um and consistently so uh
than outside of egypt
what we do next to understanding the top
amplifiers is take the 100
top engagers we manually code whether or
not they're located um in egypt outside
of egypt what their nationality is
and then what their profession is or
what sector they worked in uh depending
uh or relying on kind of uh information
that they post in their own twitter bios
a lot of people will link to a linkedin
page or a professional website
so from this oh and i should note you
know um the nodes will appear
larger if they're central right so if
they're being engaged quite a bit
uh here this is muhammad ali's account
so what you can see here is that
the tall amplifiers right even though i
just showed you that most of the
engagement is coming from inside of
egypt the top amp suppliers are located
outside of egypt so they're doing a lot
of this amplification that matters
second they're egyptian so they're
egyptians that are located outside of
the country again suggesting that
there's this transnational
political sphere where these things are
being spread and that matters right i
mean it makes them much more credible in
terms of
why they would be interested in this
information why they would be spreading
it
finally
when we look at the after type what we
find is that there are a number of media
personalities that are extremely
influential and uh active in terms of
amplifying muhammad ali's content
right and these individuals um
when we looked into the data tend to be
part of the anti-cc
independent media based in journey um
this will become important in just a
couple slides these are particularly
influential kinds of users right they
are deemed credible
they're semi-celebrities in ways that
matter for again you know the spread of
information
there's also high numbers of politicians
in exiles activists and academics
all of whom are in exile outside of the
country
finally one more slide here on um
thinking through amplification
as i mentioned um muhammad ali used
hashtags uh that called not only for
being you know anti-regime but also for
specific protests
here um we can see that again you know
inside and outside egypt are engaging
these hashtags at very similar rates
and it corresponds with some of the
larger protests so this is going to be
september 27th there's a huge spike
similar to here
again suggesting right that this
information matters for mobilization
finally turning to consumers as i
mentioned these are most likely to be
the protesters in our story
um we start with youtube data
[Music]
uh september 2nd is when these videos
are going to be posted there's a huge a
spike um initially
uh almost five uh uh 500 000 views in
one day there's also an interesting
backlash effect so by october 15th the
egyptian state has stepped in really
shut down protests
doesn't seem to make the the content any
less popular
and i should say that in this period of
analysis there's 3.3 million views so
this is a pretty viral um
video
we also see you know these numbers are
not going to be anywhere near a majority
of people watching this content but when
people publicly engage with they tend to
be more positive right so they're liking
the video on youtube at a much higher
rate than they are disliking and again
uh these trends kind of um correlate not
only with protests but with views more
generally
now the most difficult part of what
we're trying to do here is linking
information consumption with protest
behavior
that's something obviously happens at an
individual level it's kind of hard to
capture
so what we try to do is first we break
it down by governorate
so this is the google trends data again
much more of a private approach to
thinking about people engaging with this
content
we see relative interest concentrated in
the red sea governor at pina
damienta cairo
and
giza
yes
um
what i can say is that outside of the
red sea governorate which for various
reasons is highly policed this is where
most of the tourism in egypt happens
um the red sea is also important so it's
very highly police
everywhere but the red sea saw the
largest number of protests between 3 and
11 in the period under
analysis
but we want to think about this in a
much more fine-grained level
so what we do is look at the
protest data
everywhere that more than one protest
happened
uh is listed here so these are our most
active spaces
um and it's interesting you know they're
in suez and cairo which are highly urban
but they're also
you know in the middle of nowhere egypt
what we do is match these districts
akin essentially to
an american county
with districts that are the same in
terms of a level of urbanness
morsi vote in 2012 so something about
opposition to the state or anti-islamist
and population
but
they don't have any protest
what we do then is find
public facebook pages
um you might be familiar with these
these are community pages where people
tend to talk about things like schools
and potholes and
um you know broken street lights
what we do is scrape it to see if
they're
if they're talking about any of this
right at a very local level
and we find that they're talking about
the oppositional content in very
different ways
so
this the blue here is going to be places
where protests occurred
the pink is going to be places where
they did not occur
what we see here is that places where
protests occurred
talked about muhammad ali's oppositional
content posted it discussed it prior to
the start of protest
and then they they stopped talking about
it and we think there's some kind of
repressive backlash there where they're
no longer willing to talk about
something that is potentially costly
in the non-protest areas they only talk
about that content after protest so
they're learning something
you know about this oppositional content
from uh likely you know nationwide uh
news coverage of these
so we think of this you know in the the
quality of literature is much more of a
smoking gun to say there is something
about local information consumption of
this oppositional information that
matters for whether or not you see
protests or whether or not you're
learning about that information later
so just to recap
here exiles in our story are really
important for introducing amplifying
information they contribute to
information cascades which are so
important for getting people to protest
but they don't need interest right
you'll remember in all of the graphs
there was more online engagement from
domestic users than exili users
finally we show that there's at a very
fine green level a correlation between
local protests and um
local consumption of this oppositional
information
as i mentioned there may be two things
that are somewhat specific to this case
although you know we're only looking at
egypt it would certainly be worth
thinking about egypt and comparative
perspective the influencer it's not only
credible right he as the kids say has
received from having been
personally involved in
uh
being um an army contractor he's not
partisan so a place like egypt being
identified as either as some of us more
non-islamist in meaningful ways might
have made his
the information you know less credible
to lots of people
on the other side
he emphasizes throughout his videos his
blue collar background right so he's
kind of
an every man in this situation
and then as i mentioned he had also
worked as a celebrity so he's very
polished he's very charismatic his
videos are shot
um
you know kind of in like a selfie style
but they're very polished right
second
because he works in the entertainment
industry he seems to have
a lot of followers who are in the media
and the entertainment sectors
and in the literature even in the united
states right um people tend to be
bored of politics they don't like
politics celebrities can get people
excited about politics and so he is a
high number of these people who are
considered to be icons in the
communications literature that are
retweeting
especially early his work
okay so to bring it back
to kind of a higher level what i'm
hoping to do here is think about the
microfoundations of both revolution and
defeated revolution as well as
democratization
so quite a few of the activists that i
am talking about
in both the paper that i'm working on
with alex and in the book um
you know these are
people who not only planned and executed
the revolution but they continued it to
the extent that it continued beyond
2011. um
and the political science literature has
talked a lot about how there are
biographical effects of having
participated
in movements
here i'm interested in this concept of
you know how is participating
in a revolution and then a defeated
revolution affect the rest of your life
right um for many of these people that
happen in their early 20s
they still have a long time you know to
kind of grapple with the effects and and
it's completely understudied in the
literature
second i'm interested in kind of
um i'm doing this in other projects as
well with one of our colleagues here dan
mattely
um
coerced migration is a very interesting
form of migration
um and we've spent a lot of time in
political science thinking about
transnational repression right what
regimes are doing to kind of
uh punish activists beyond their borders
but we think less about how this is kind
of inadvertently creating transnational
opposition and so we want to think a
little bit more critically about
how the way in which regimes use course
migration if they use course migration
shapes opposition in ways that has
you know important effects on domestic
politics
then finally
perhaps a bit hopefully because i know a
lot of this has not been
particularly hopeful
um
you know the folks that are currently
located outside of egypt who are doing
things like
introducing oppositional information
and uh mobilizing protests will likely
be a source of democratization in the
future right uh most of the arab spring
uprisings did not result in uh
meaningful democratization it they very
much resulted in increased
authoritarianism
as a result most of the open space for
contestation is now outside of the
country so just like 2010 to 2011 the
arab spring uprisings um you know relied
on decades of people working as
activists i think any kind of future
democratization will too
and in the case of the arab spring right
like where we are now with uh regards to
oppression likely those activists are
going to be the ones located outside of
the country
um so with that
i will say thank you thank you again to
the program for
um helping me to continue this research
over the last year and a half
people from the audience would like to
ask
questions now
i'll
pass them to
professor nugent
yeah true
yeah so i have two questions so
the
first is uh
sort of a
and
i was wondering whether this just
applies to exile in the context of
defeated revolution
or if it's broadly applicable to
any setting where perhaps there's
extreme democratic backsliding so i was
thinking particularly in the case of
turkey
but then also in settings where one side
is defeated in a civil war and
uh individuals are forced to go abroad
but still there are some
attempt to
try and influence politics but back home
so uh
like i was wondering
sort of the extent to which
you think your
argument applies to
those settings
like revolutionary settings in
particular or whether it can apply to a
broader set of settings
and then the second question i have is
regarding sort of the diagram that you
have where individuals abroad sort of
have these choices
to
either remain
active in sort of
politics background as exiles uh
or just change to some other kind of
political activism or just disengage all
together i was wondering the extent to
which individuals kind of change like
sort of shift between those
uh
modes
of behavior um but overall really
fascinating project
should i answer okay yeah so
your first question is a really
interesting one because
as i mentioned at the beginning of the
talk of the 345
revolutionary situations that don't
so 123 of them are successful right
meaning they result in democratization
in a meaningful way
the rest of them
fail in lots of different ways right so
some become civil wars some just go back
to the same authoritarianism
some go back to worse authoritarianism
my case um killian clark has done some
really interesting work on this concept
of counter-revolution
egypt and i think he's right on this
although i think the concept of defeated
revolution can apply to a lot of
different things
um
he calls it counter-revolution where you
actually did have a civilian government
right or a change in the old guard in a
meaningful way
and i think he says that there's 22
cases of that
where you have
meaningful change in government and then
a reversal
so i think at the very least it applies
to those 22 cases um
some of the other cases that i'm looking
at in the book so iraq you end up with
exiles before like basically under
saddam hussein that's not necessarily
the result of a failed revolution
um in libya you also part of that is
you know there are moments of kind of
civil war there's also moments of just
higher oppression
um in syria it's a defeated revolution
that has become a civil war so it's not
exactly
it's both right you know that you can't
kind of
separate that both of these things are
related um so i'm trying to think about
defeated revolution as a broad category
that then there would be
lots of different ways that revolutions
are failed or failing um
yeah and in terms of that graph i mean i
think there's
i think there probably is some switching
and at this point it's been interesting
to see
over the last 10 years how people have
evolved in their stance right so people
who have gone from thinking that
revolution is pointless to thinking okay
well now the revolution must be must be
global instead of local
it does seem like most folks who decide
to
cease being an activist stay
out of politics that's not the case for
every single person but for the most
part they're
making choices based on personal
decisions right their children or their
family needing to go back to school
financial necessity um or they've
experienced such a terrible form of
repression like they're unable to keep
being active politically
there is more
i don't know if it's flip-flopping or
changing within people who continue to
be active on domestic issues and those
who who start to think about things as a
broader
issue but
it's pretty clear when someone's saying
okay i'm mobilizing
on you know the cause of political
uh detainees in egypt versus political
detainees and you know thinking about
this in egypt right like they're the way
in which they talk about it does
differentiate between like whether
they're thinking about it as a broad
category or if it's like in egypt
specifically this is the issue
um
so yeah i think there's more overlap in
those two categories as people
you know frankly come to terms with
are they going to be staying in their
new location for longer what else is
happening in their life are there new
focal points right around which they
could be bringing the egyptian issue
into like the green movement or into the
migration movement um some of it's a bit
strategic in terms of that as well
thanks
um so i had two questions one for each
part
so for the first part of the talk i was
curious what
so you mentioned while and
taking different paths in their activism
and i was wondering if you had a sense
of why their paths diverged and you
mentioned trauma and i know they were
both exposed to trauma but i'm not sure
if you have any insight on why their
paths might have taken such different
trajectories
and then
the second question that i had is you
mentioned
transnational repression and how mo ali
was
sort of shut down eventually and so i
wonder
what if you
could talk a little bit about
how
exilic opposition activism differs from
activism at home if
you are still at the mercy of
transnational repression if your family
members can be
targeted by the regime
um you know why it is it just like an
oversight that the regime didn't notice
these people but then once they pop up
they get shut down or you know i feel
like there could be some dynamic there
uh strategically that would be
interesting to think about yeah these
are great questions so in terms of the
individual variation
i think in the case of
and
obviously you know people are quite
idiosyncratic but i think in this case
it had to do with
their individual reactions to trauma and
repression so they they had very similar
experiences you know i think
one of them you know kind of as a result
had really terrible ptsd resulted in
kind of
a crumbling of his both his personal and
professional and political life
um the other one you know channeled it
in different ways
um
so i i think that's that's probably
what's explaining that variation
um second
rate so this idea of transnational
repression this goes to your question
too so
initially they're not directly
repressing muhammad ali um
they do shut down his account every time
there was kind of those vertical spikes
you can see that either things are being
deleted or the account is being shut
down
um so i think online transactional
repression is particularly interesting
because it's essentially costless for a
regime the other kinds of transnational
repression that i was uh referring to in
the case of ali is that they pressure
some of his family back home and then
the egyptian state has been investing in
kind of its overseas repression or
surveillance they've been beefing up uh
the intelligence collection at their
embassies and what ali claims in some
some later videos is that he
is being trailed you know by an egyptian
agent um
so i think there's a couple of things
you know i think the fact that cc
responded to him made him more credible
right we see the spikes there's clearly
a reaction
um and i think he did so because the
information that ali was putting out was
particularly damning
um
although you know that was probably a
badly calculated risk right had he
ignored it maybe it wouldn't have gone
viral the way it did
um
i think
yeah i mean i think regimes make
mistakes on these things they either
don't notice or they think it's not that
big a deal um i think once the 27th
happened those were pretty large
protests particularly in a country right
now where it's highly repressive um
after that i mean i think you see the
regime then say
okay you know we really need to squash
this both in terms of a physical
presence and shutting down those
accounts
you know and trailing ali so
i mean in some ways right this this time
period is not that long it's between
september 2nd
and september 27th right where we get
introduction of information and then
major protests um so
i guess they're moving as quickly as
they can
that might be part of it too
i have actually a question as well so is
regarding the ability of the regime to
shut down
[Music]
the
way that the activists uh sort of
communicate
uh so some of these uh i imagine that
they
use some of the
i don't know so facebook whatsapp
so
is there like any pressure on these
companies both inside and outside to
just uh shut down whatever the regime is
not liking
and um
and either and what would be also the
reaction
for the activists themselves maybe to
transfer to use another
way of communicating that cannot be
sort of surveyed the same way yeah
absolutely so
in terms of
the first right so the pressure on the
company is the so
in this case they shut down
they use on twitter you know if you're
familiar with twitter you can report
content right for various reasons it's
offensive or it's politically
inflammatory
it seems like what the regime did was
was flag arabic language content said it
was inflammatory
twitter immediately
um
removed those accounts and that content
eventually
i don't really know what goes on behind
the scenes but eventually it was
reviewed and they found that that you
know it wasn't actually politically
inflammatory and so they reinstated the
accounts um
there was also you know a couple of
twitter threads where people were
collecting
names of people who had been targeted so
then there was a sense of okay all these
people were tweeting about this thing
right that's not politically
inflammatory it's just
oppositional information
um and there was an investigative report
done by a journalist outside of the
country
um i think i have another graph
here of
one additional thing in addition to
shutting down
the accounts
the egyptian
state me see
nope i don't have it
um
they are able to
basically make certain websites
unavailable
and you can see
access to twitter and facebook
if i had the graph you could see like
it's basically limited by 20 to 30 at
different moments um so they're able to
do it on a couple different levels but
you know this investigative journalist
demonstrated
it wasn't because they were saying
something like you know use violence or
whatever it was really they were just
retweeting this information um
and i do think you know what i really
enjoy about our paper is that we're able
to use
sources from a bunch of different
platforms
uh data from a number of different
sources
we do see that these things are
happening in tandem right like so
there's a lot of the information cascade
is happening across different platforms
obviously you know there's also secret
ways to talk about this stuff whatsapp
and signal they're obviously doing that
as well it's just harder to to you
to find public data on that kind of
stuff
um there's been some interesting papers
on also like telegram
and clubhouse right ways that people
when the internet gets shut down you
know
when facebook gets shut down when
twitter is being um monitored using
clubhouse can sometimes be an
alternative to that so they're
definitely being strategic in terms of
that as well
but the regime also sort of
has have they sort of shut down or do
they have what is their approach to
these companies working inside
yeah i mean
this is a very timely question i think
with some of the debates about like what
what role is facebook supposed to play
in
society generally in a democracy and an
autocracy um
for the most part they've been fine with
them existing they just also put
limitations on it um you know like
facebook messenger is a way that a lot
of egyptians communicate in country
i think they know it's like not
encrypted you know it's there's certain
things you don't say there
um
yeah at different moments i think uh
whatsapp has been difficult to access in
the region because there's been a block
on it um so the regimes you know are
clearly using the technology that they
can to make it more difficult to do this
kind of coordination
um it's still easier to like police a
street though right than to police an
online platform
so that tends to be you know where
they're focusing their efforts
good
um
any more questions yeah yeah so
in the second project the uh fair
comparison of the districts is really
interesting um and i was wondering if
you happen to have if there's data out
there
that you could where you could do that
same comparison but then see
if those
matched districts have different levels
of protest activity during actual during
the arab spring like eight years earlier
um
and
like the extent to which there's been
some sort of like kind of longer term
legacy of
arab spring mobilization that can then
sort of
contribute to
the
sort of
post-counter-revolutionary
period and the propensity of people to
uh try at least like maybe it's maybe
just like a place
yeah
i i don't have that but that's a really
great suggestion we do see that
one thing we we wondered was
whether they were more active anyway
and
there's no clear pattern here so the the
protests on average the protest
localities are slightly
more active but not significantly so in
terms of just number of posts
um our measurement ends up being a
percentage of total posts but
you know i can say that they're at least
not like significantly different in
terms of how much they're talking about
local issues but that would be
interesting to see this data set um from
the cairo based data institute does go
back you know quite a ways um
yeah it could be interesting to think
like are there already networks here
that are being activated
um
and if not then that's really
interesting because right new ones are
being activated during like
a highly repressive time yeah
yeah that's a great suggestion
egypt like so much of the attention
paid to you like that your spring
activity in egypt is paid to what's
happening in cairo and there's just
really not a ton about like what's
happening in a lot of
uh
other areas in egypt like i mean at
least
in sort of the
popular press but then also in like
academic literature there's not as much
right
yeah there's jason brownlee i think has
written about like the cairo bias in
egyptian scholarship which i think we're
all guilty of but
um
particularly with protests i think urban
bias is
absolutely the case and in this case you
know a lot of these protests didn't
happen in urban centers which is
interesting right like that's not really
the
historical pattern of protests in egypt
so yeah i mean is it is it mobilizing
new networks is there something about
i don't know even the way in which like
the regime has been highly policing
certain areas and not policing other
areas you know and trying to strategize
and
um you know maximize the effectiveness
of their repressive you know capacity um
it's a really yeah that's a really
interesting question and we'll
definitely do that well and it may be
because like
cairo has become such a focal point for
the regime that actually opens up space
for people in
these smaller communities to actually
organize
yeah well in egypt is also just a
fascinating case because you have
the
you know if you were to look at the
uh
distribution of population it's like
it's a very concentrated distribution
which means there are certain
ways in which the regime can
police it very easily but it's a huge
country at the same time right and it's
not like there aren't people in the
countryside who are also really unhappy
with what's happening and the internet
might be particularly effective at
mobilizing those groups you know
relative to like word of mouth right
just based on uh density of population
any more questions no we don't have more
questions here so
uh i think that's it so thank you very
much
for the presentation and um
best of luck with the remaining of your
research